[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a las vegas tourism company called love
cloud recently began offering flights
specifically for people hoping to join
the so-called mile high club that's
right starting at one thousand dollars
up to six passengers can board a
luxurious cessna 414 twin-engine
aircraft and embark on a 45-90 minute
flight where they're free to spend the
entire time boinking
but if you're into that and one thousand
dollars seems a little steep don't worry
we here at the ambrofen show have
created a virtually identical experience
that's completely free for anyone in our
audience we call it
the tiny metal sex box now
at any point during our show any two
audience members are welcome to step
inside the tiny metal sex box to get it
on
the interior of the tiny metal sex box
is made of unadorned industrial
stainless steel which both keeps costs
down and makes cleanup a breeze
now when you're ready to do the deed
choose any position from missionary to
pretty much just missionary and
unlike a dinky little cessna the tiny
metal sex box has no weight limit so
feel free to cram as many hot sweaty
audience members as you can
so while the tiny metal sex box may not
be able to actually fly our crew will
ensure that you get the extra
stimulation that only turbulence can
provide
and remember
while you're inside the tiny metal sex
box we'll be out here unable to focus on
anything but the sound of skin squeaking
against cold steel like this
what a thrill so if you're looking for a
cheap easy way to spice up your love
life just get tickets to the amber
ruffin show and give the tiny metal sex
box a whirl tiny metal sex box the
product that'll have you saying i wish
you hadn't put those four words together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you